[Music]
[Music]
who lives in a pineapple under the sea
spongebob squarepants in his latest
adventure the spongebob movie sponge on
the run we learn more about spongebob's
faithful companion gary the snail
who has gone missing his mysterious
disappearance prompts spongebob and his
friend patrick to set off on an epic
journey
far beyond bikini bottom they must
explore a wacky world featuring keanu
reeves jilting thrills and plenty of
candy coated treats that will appeal to
any audience
here's everything you need to know
before you watch the spongebob movie
sponge on the run capturing the cheerful
chaos of childhood and the guise of a
friendly sea sponge and his friends
spongebob squarepants quickly gained an
audience of loyal viewers when it first
premiered
viewers were attracted to the happy
antics and adventures of the optimistic
and resilient spongebob squarepants
who loves to try new things and always
looks out for his friends and neighbors
in the community known as bikini bottom
the animated comedy made its first
appearance on television in 1999
the show which was created by marine
biology instructor turned animator
stephen hillenburg
drew upon the knowledge of the creator
about sea life
but the show spotlighted the wackier
aspects of marine creatures which made
the series
much more palatable to younger audiences
they could learn
while being entertained by the show's
delightful creatures
the series became a smash hit worldwide
there's no way out you're stuck in the
middle of nowhere
with spongebob patrick
well this is the end the success of the
first three seasons of the series led to
the first
film the spongebob squarepants movie
which was originally
intended to conclude the show
[Music]
however the characters were so popular
that the series has continued until this
day
like the first movie the second film
followed the animated characters into a
live-action world
the crew pursued a thief who had stolen
something valuable from their undersea
world
the new movie starts before the
television series and promises to answer
questions about the origin of spongebob
squarepants
yes he's still a porous sea sponge but
how did his friendships with other
characters begin
and how did the beloved gary the snail
who lives with spongebob and meows like
a cat
get involved with the spunky sponge and
perhaps most importantly
how did spongebob come to wear his
signature squarepants
veteran animator tim hill who helped
develop the original series and
also co-wrote the first big screen
version wrote and directed this film
he has also helmed several other popular
animated films like alvin and the
chipmunks and
garfield a tale of two kitties so he
understands what is needed to make an
enjoyable and successful feature-length
animated film
familiar voices who will be returning
include all the principal cast
led by tom kenny as spongebob
squarepants bill figerbachy as best
friend patrick starr
roger bumpus as the lovable grumpy
squidward tentacles
and clanty brown as restaurant owner mr
krabs
and the film isn't just for children in
addition to the familiar voices were
also promised the presence of keanu
reeves
aquafina snoop dogg danny trejo
tiffany haddish and reggie watts the
film will mix live-action footage with
the animation which is being presented
in cgi
this means those of you who remember the
show from when it first began can enjoy
the nostalgia of clever and comic
characters
all appearing in shiny new modern
surroundings
truly the best of both worlds so now you
know and now you can go
watch the spongebob movie sponge on the
run on digital platforms including
fandango now
starting march 4th
you